[Music]
our main story tonight concerns Facebook
the worst place to wish happy birthday
to a friend other than a funeral now
Facebook has been in the news a lot
recently over concerns about everything
from privacy to fake news to Russian
trolls but tonight we're actually going
to go in a different direction and focus
on his behavior overseas because
Facebook has been expanding aggressively
abroad more than half its revenue come
from outside the US and eighty percent
of its users now live in foreign
countries posting things like this yes
that is that's an international version
of the in my feelings challenge the
thing that took Facebook and Instagram
by storm after being popularized by the
Shiggy show and you can learn more about
all of that in my new book I don't know
what any of these words mean but my
staff assures me it makes sense for
years Facebook's founder Mark Zuckerberg
pushed his utopian idea that all
connections are good connections with
feel-good ads showing him bringing the
Internet to the world and Facebook
employees proudly saying things like
this by connecting the world people
realize that there are other people in
the world who have different lives in
them and that maybe their lives could be
better and then amazing things happen
you want to do something big and you
have this access to you know 1.2 billion
people what can you do is just limited
by your imagination look connecting
billions of people does sound great but
it's also important to remember that
when it comes to the Internet a certain
number of those people are then going to
say Jews control sharks who did 9/11 and
you really have to think that through
unfortunately thinking things through
has never really been Facebook strong
point there early motto was famously
move fast and break things a sentiment
which Zuckerberg has explained this way
we want to build our culture and our
infrastructure so that we just try to
move you know one or two clicks faster
than than other companies and you know
sometimes we go too fast and we mess up
a bunch of stuff and then we have to fix
it and that's cool is that cool is that
cool at all mark because that seems like
maybe the most reckless corporate motto
since the hindenburg companies fly fast
and smokes
and a big bag of hydrogen how did you
not foresee the problems that were
heading your way and make no mistake
Facebook has broken things overseas
sometimes they were small for instance
over the summer there was an earthquake
in Indonesia and while Facebook
undeniably connected people there it
wasn't necessarily in the way the
situation demanded as this international
news report shows normally Facebook
sends the balloon and the confetti
animations to users wishing each other
well
however the Indonesian work for
congratulations selamat can also mean
unheard or to survive so when Facebook
users posted messages saying I hope
people will survive Facebook give them
celebratory animations yeah
that's not ideal is it because there's a
time and a place for balloons and it's
very rarely after the word survived in
fact let me prove that to you
I have some terrible news we may have to
eat each other to survive no no that's
the worst time for that and look look if
if embarrassing mistranslations were the
only problems that Facebook had that
would be one thing but the company has
made some hugely consequential mistakes
overseas and that is what tonight's
story is about in the Philippines and
Cambodia Facebook has been accused of
empowering authoritarians in Sri Lanka
India and Indonesia viral rumors and
hateful comments on Facebook have been
linked to outbreaks of deadly violence
but for the worst distillation of what
Facebook can do to a country just look
at Myanmar the country who thinks so
little about you didn't even realize
that's not Myanmar that's Mikhail
Gorbachev's birthmark
this is Myanmar now Myanmar
also known as Burma was for decades cut
off from the world under military
dictatorships but in recent years as its
transition to a quasi civilian
government internet use there especially
a Facebook has exploded in 2013 just
over 1 percent of citizens had internet
access but now 18 million people are on
Facebook thanks in part to becoming
pre-installed on mobile phones and heavy
promotion by service providers who
didn't charge Facebook usage against
data plans yeah we can use Facebook for
free except for looking at photos and
watching videos everything is free we'll
use Facebook for free and ask the things
we want to know I'll use empty tea and
post everything to Facebook it's free
let's use Facebook for free with MPC ok
just quick question is Facebook free cuz
I'm worried that commercial didn't quite
make it clear so with Facebook's so easy
to access it basically became the
internet so much so that people in
Myanmar use the terms internet and
Facebook interchangeably and look some
people there use Facebook for fun that
guy you saw earlier lives in Myanmar
while other people find it to be a
complete waste of time like this
irritating teacher everybody said easy
it's my phone playing games I hate I
hate I don't like it's a terrible look
likes boys Facebook is a toilet
find it okay I get that he's annoyed but
calling Facebook a toilet is a little
unfair to toilets because they make
go away whereas Facebook retains
disseminate to your acquaintances
and reminds you of from seven years
ago or what allow the corporation's to
put their in front of you what I'm
saying is there is a purity and
integrity to toilets that Facebook
seriously lacks but Facebook's issues in
Myanmar go well beyond distracted
teenagers because if you have glanced at
the not Trump section of the newspaper
at all recently you are probably aware
that Myanmar is a majority Buddhist
country with a long history of religious
and ethnic tensions particularly with
regard to the row hinge er a mostly
Muslim group in the western part of
Myanmar in 2017 and military executed a
brutal campaign of ethnic cleansing so
far about seven hundred and twenty-five
thousand role hinge about three-quarters
of the population have fled to
Bangladesh to escape government troops
one estimate puts the death toll
conservatively at around 10,000 people
and to be clear Facebook didn't cause
that I feel comfortable saying it Mark
Zuckerberg not guilty genocide in
Myanmar as of this taping but but and it
is a big but by all accounts Facebook
absolutely did inflamed pre-existing
tensions there in fact a report on
Myanmar prepared by independent UN
investigators said Facebook has been a
useful instrument for those seeking to
spread hate and it is weird to hear
something that started out as frivolous
be described like that it's like if five
years from now you and investigators
called bubble tea and aggressive threat
to human rights holy I mean
honestly I never really liked it but
Jesus Christ
but hate speech against Muslims and
especially the row hinge er flourished
on Facebook posted by military leaders
and politicians as well as prominent
Buddhist monks like Ashton were are - -
Muslims have a place here in Burma we
can't repeat his actual response its
r-rated but essentially he said Muslims
were defecating on Burma threatening its
very existence you don't like them very
much
mahjongg i don't accept them why did i
because they're deceiving the world they
want to take over the whole country that
monk is so hateful he has actually been
called the Burmese bin Laden that's
right a Buddhist monk is known as the
Burmese bin Laden which is as jarring as
if you found out there's a Care Bear
known as the one who because to be
honest I always thought wish bear would
be the one who I mean look at him
that Beth Fox
lerato had hundreds of thousands of
followers on Facebook and he uses pages
to wreak havoc including spreading false
accusations that a Muslim business owner
had raped a buddhist employee a post
that helped instigate riots in the city
of mandalay in 2014 in which two people
were killed and around 20 others injured
and yet despite repeated warnings about
where our to facebook didn't get around
to banning him until earlier this year
and that is just one example of the
extent to which facebook became an echo
chamber of Islamophobia one local
official told reporters he was proud to
oversee a Muslim free village even
though he admitted he had never even met
a Muslim before adding I have to thank
Facebook because it is giving me the
true information in Myanmar and here is
what happened when ABC talked to people
in the streets there most local people
here get their news via Facebook and
judging by what people have told us they
are not getting the whole picture what
do you think about the
I think they are terrorists they are
extra they're making problems everything
I could gather information from Facebook
what does Facebook say they want to
occupy our land and our people that is
very very dangerous because no one
should be judged by the worst things
people say about them on Facebook if I
were judge by that you'd think I was a
cuck twit a prime example of why
abortion should be more readily
available and that I look like a
distressed bird in a pet shop trying
desperately to get your attention and I
ask you is any of that apart from that
last one really fair I would say no I
would argue not so so how the did
so much hate speech and violence
inciting content stay up for so long
because it's not like Facebook doesn't
have rules they have a lot of them their
own internal materials get into details
like which sort of anuses photoshopped
onto faces they're willing to allow this
is true they even cite graphic examples
such as this image of Trump with an anus
for a mouth that is apparently allowed
by the way because he is a public figure
Taylor Swift with anuses for eyes also
allowed for the same reason but this
image of kim jeong-hoon with an anus for
a mouth is apparently not okay because i
quote it also displays a sex toy
inserted into the anus but that still
leaves gray areas doesn't it for
instance what if I display a meatball
sub being inserted into that same mouth
anus is a meatball sub a sex toy could
you not argue that meatballs are the
anal beads of Italy and by the way Olive
Garden that slogan is free for you to
use
look you can have it it's yours look you
can quibble you can absolutely quibble
with where Facebook draws its lines and
the broader discussion of private
companies policing speech is an
important one but the point is Facebook
does have standards that are enforced in
a number of ways they have artificial
intelligence that automatically detects
some objectionable content and removes
it they also rely on users like you and
me to flag objectionable content which
is then reviewed by human moderators
it's something most social media
companies do and it is a thankless job
as you can see from this training
session run by a Content moderation
company in India here the person is not
naked but you can see their exxor shape
is visible now this lady's now here it's
very much obvious that intensely sees
focusing on but part the camera is
focusing on but part it will fall under
nudity it's not proper nudity but it
will fall under nudity I'm sorry I'm
absolutely calling it that guy is
definitely focusing on the buttocks but
as Facebook themselves will tell you
policing nudity is the easy part what's
harder is defining and spotting
misinformation hate speech and that is
what Myanmar has been drowning in and
Facebook system failed them at every
stage first their a I didn't work
because Facebook's technology isn't
compatible with me amaz language fonts
which you know not great but fine that
just meant that they badly needed
Burmese people to flag content for them
but to do that it really might have
helped if things like their community
standards and reporting systems had been
in Burmese which they weren't until late
2015 which isn't great in the country
where almost no one speaks English just
imagine if Facebook Facebook's interface
here was in Burmese you would have no
way of knowing which button did what in
fact that's not even Facebook's
interface that's just a list of
dinosaurs ranked from most to least
and by the way
Stegosaurus is way too far down on that
list
Stella Soros is basically the wish bear
of dinosaurs seriously
that bear can get it but but wait wait
because it gets worse even content that
did get flagged in Myanmar often didn't
get taken down and one reason with that
may be that Facebook had shockingly few
Burmese speaking content reviewers how
many you know I'll just let this Reuters
reporter tell you back in 2014 they had
one person they hired a second in early
2015 they out sourced an operation
they'd been doing that for a while but
they had had no burmese speakers at all
until 2015 when they hired - it's true
first they had one then they doubled it
to two and through outsourcing added two
more so full and I don't know what the
exact right number of Burmese speakers
for Facebook is but it probably
shouldn't be possible for the sum total
of them to be decimated in a tandem bike
accident and it's not like Facebook can
plead ignorance or surprise about any of
this multiple civil society groups and
individuals try to warn them as far back
as 2013 five years ago that they face
trouble in Myanmar and Facebook itself
now admits that they move too slowly
though Zuckerberg insists that they're
now making progress they've hired 60
burmese speakers me recently told
members of congress that they're looking
for more we're hiring dozens of more
Burmese language content reviewers
because hate speech is very language
specific it's hard to do it without
people who speak the local language and
we need to ramp up our effort there
dramatically hate speech is language
specific it's a little weird to hear a
guy who's been universally lauded as a
genius and a visionary say something
that's completely obvious as if it's a
brand new idea to him it's as if Steve
Jobs called everyone together for his
brand new discovery mrs. Doubtfire was
just the dad in a costume yeah we know
Steve
did you not get that I thought you were
smart I don't trust my iPhone now but
for all his reassuring words many argue
that Zuckerberg still hasn't done nearly
enough hate speech is still widespread
on Facebook in Myanmar last month four
months after Zuckerberg promised to do
better
Reuters found more than a thousand
Burmese language posts attacking the row
hinge ER and other Muslims that were
still on Facebook and short you could
say well come on Reuters was actively
looking for those but you know who else
could do that maybe a company worth 500
billion dollars
Reuters doesn't have 500 billion dollars
their journalist doesn't even seem to
have a decent webcam get the man a
decent webcam Reuters his work is
important and despite its 60
hole Burmese speakers Facebook is still
struggling with the language there in
fact earlier this year there community
standards were so badly missed
translated into Burmese that instead of
saying we take our role in keeping abuse
of our service seriously they said we
take our role seriously by abusing our
services and small things like that
really matter
even punctuation can change the meaning
of a sentence for example and this is
true Bill Cosby once wrote a book that
I'm guessing was meant to be called come
on people but they admitted the comma so
it read come on people
and deep down perhaps that's when we
should have known and look look I am NOT
saying that the challenges Facebook is
facing and not significant but for a
company that moves fast and break things
they have sure moved slowly in trying to
fix them and until they do it is
painfully obvious that everyone should
be treating anything on their site with
extreme skepticism and see Facebook for
what it actually is a fetid swamp of
mistruths and outright lies interspersed
with the occasional reminder of a dead
pet that's it
that's what it is so instead of
producing idyllic ads about connecting
the world at the very very least
Facebook should be producing ads that
prepare countries for how to deal with
their product Oh suggest something like
this hi we're Facebook we're connecting
the world
and we're coming to your country whether
you like it or not so there's one thing
about Facebook you should probably know
somewhere between eighty and a hundred
percent of what's on our site is
complete my Facebook
page is full of lies about how happy I
am my Facebook page say I go to yoga
I'll be like three times my Facebook
page says I'm a 19 year old girl all my
photos are of me we are baby but I don't
have baby fun
we at Facebook believe in giving
everyone a voice without worrying too
much about what that voice then chooses
to say I mean how bad could it be I
don't believe the Holocaust happened Oh
yikes can someone please explain to me
why what Charlie Rose did was so wrong
I wouldn't post that but you can George
Soros invented mosquitoes Hillary
Clinton created aids yeah I'm sure about
that there is only one old cent winner
moving back and forth very fast look
it's not our place to tell you you're
wrong we're about making connections can
you connect me to my brother
sure can you connect me to coca-cola oh
we can absolutely do that but I gotta
admit I'm an animal a go-getter matter I
mean familiar I'm not sure what you just
said but it sounded great the point is
Facebook is a platform anyone can use to
do good or bad it's riddled with
and quite honestly we're never
gonna be able to control or contain it
so before you use our site for the first
time there's something you badly need to
remember Facebook is full of
Facebook is full of we spoke with
John see Tom to base boogie no mirrors
por nada first movie John said mom
Facebook are the rust disgusting got a
lily left of this book in a posh way
they like karma so in my team Bunton ah
coilette Facebook outlook on junk
Facebook's our toilet and God willing
your country will survive it sure we've
really gotta fix that Facebook
we're toilet
[Laughter]
[Applause]